European Union space programs Galileo
and Copernicus are one of the most
successful examples of the benefits and
strengths that European integration can
deliver not only to European citizens or
to the world as a whole with 18
satellites currently in orbit and over
30 planned in the next 10 to 15 years
European Union is the largest
institutional customer for launch
services in Europe and one of the
largest globally space technologies data
and services have become indispensable
in the daily lives of our citizens from
using mobile phones and car navigation
systems watching satellite TV or
withdrawing cash space policy can help
boost jobs growth and investments in
Europe for this reason the European
Union will invest over 12 billion euros
in space activities for the period 2014
to 2020 Copernicus Europe's earth
observation program provides free full
open access to data for your businesses
to use it already helps saving lives at
sea improves our response to natural
disasters such as earthquakes and allows
farmers to better manage their crops we
now need to encourage businesses to make
use of that data then Galileo Europe saw
satellite navigation system that is also
starting to bear fruit we are very
pleased with the performance of the
initial services launched last year but
the keys to success is again market
uptake and these what we will do in the
coming years
finally on centinall to be images these
satellites deliver data that in
particular benefit farmers builders
fishermen and anyone who needs rapid
access to up-to-the-minute data on
conditions on the ground